pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
key
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
et
alain gelly j'ai bien travaillé mon ami
mieux de votre chance mais tu te bien
répandu où j'étais sur les chronos
j'avais bien allongé sur mon bras aux
métiers goûtez y paraît mais ces métiers
qu'on mangeait bien vite
[Musique]
m
enfants
[Musique]
yalouz est un jour comme ça ça s'arrose
c'est vrai c'est votre dernière née est
oui demain matin cyril boulleaux adieu
la marée motrice d'aller se reposer ont
vécu c'est la retraite ça a du bon
et puis du pas bon qu'est ce qui te
remplace ou brunch un nouveau puisqu'il
vient c'est pas strasbourg e-paye
strasbourg
pourquoi ils ont beau briguer le cas
d'ici l'administration la trappe
[Musique]
je vous démange pas tous les deux chacun
merci j'aime bien
et ô toi c'est l'heure d'aller se
coucher par famille bassam et ne paient
pas plus ce qu'on est bien en fin de q3
à propos tu lui as dit dis quoi
quelqu'un va venir s'installer ici
demain si oui
non non pas mamie non non allocataires
coton oui un monsieur qui va louer la
chambre à côté de la tienne là haut
lisez pas qu'est ce que ça signifie tu
ne peux pas ne pas qu'ils viennent
habiter chez nous dans notre maison et
moi vois que ça m'amuse d'avoir un
étranger chez nous assure que je m'en
passerais bien des prochaines 6 mai à
faire ça arrange ont plus besoin de la
chambre pour le moment n'est pas les
moyens de refuser le loyer qu'il nous
donne tu prends maintenant tu peux
comprendre ça tu verras il est très
gentil il travaille à l'usiné
marémotrice
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'on sait que deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah c'est toi je n'avais pas entendu
bonjour bonjour patrick viau et équipe
patrick on ne dit pas le type audi
monsieur moselle
[Applaudissements]
un bonsoir monsieur vous ai pas dit
qu'ils avaient un enfant dans la chambre
à côté de la mienne à patrick c'est
notre fils pour moi le jure il faut que
je dorme alors si un gros sac à dos dans
le coup et ouais non n'ayez aucune
crainte patrick est un an centre et
stages il ne vous dis pas tu viens je
vais te présenter à monsieur mosey
patrick descend tout de suite patrie en
mai s'est laissé sommes déjà vu
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que tu fous tu veux réveiller
monsieur moselle faut pas faire des
choses comme ça patrick tu es un grand
garçon il recommence parole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça veut dire patrick je
crois que tu avais demandé d'être
raisonnable j'aime pas beaucoup ses
manières de faire un garçon toujours par
la passe au score si tu es puni des cas
continuez comme ça sur l'angle c'est le
furent madame ça ne me dérange pas
[Musique]
5/4 fait par les athlètes n'ont pas de
l'est vous fait certes a sciemment
[Applaudissements]
encore là selon ce qu'on est parti n'a
pas une machine pareil vous à perdre
d'une pièce de rechange mais je vois au
revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je faisais les matchs maghreb comme tous
les matins
basse et puis j'ai aperçu une forme
étendue c'était cette personne là où
murray sur les rochers vous l'avez
trouvé dans cette position dans cette
position
[Musique]
et
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bakou
à mi-cuisson des difficultés financières
qui ont contraint les parents de patrick
le 13 à prendre un locataire quelqu'un
va venir s'installer ici demain
l'arrivée de cet homme taciturne et
mystérieux bouleverse l'existence de
l'enfant qui le considèrent aussitôt
comme un intrus et équipe
monsieur mosey et veilleur de nuit à
l'usiné marémotrice
existe-t-il un lien entre son arrivée à
saint malo et la disparition d'une jeune
fille dont on était sans nouvelle depuis
trois jours et que l'on vient de
retrouver humains et voici maintenant
nous croisions de 8 heures itron un brio
lors savalou foncia retrouver à lens des
rosaies le corps de la jeune fille
disparue depuis trois jours il
semblerait qu'elle ait été tué de
plusieurs coups de couteau
c'est le seul renseignements qui nous
sera parvenu jusqu'à présent la
gendarmerie enquête mais on encore
trouvé aucun indice susceptible de
mettre sur la piste du meurtrier nous
espérons être en mesure de vous donner
de plus amples détails dans notre
journal de navette comme tous les
mercredis à l'elysée
le conseil des ministres s'est réuni
sous la présidence
[Applaudissements]
alors et solange né le 15 juillet 1955
un peu plus de 18 ans elle était jolie
six coups de couteau
crime de sadiques or noir l'avait vu le
médecin
oui je pense qu'elle a été plus dans la
nuit d'avant-hier à hier entre minuit et
4 heures du matin mais ne peut pas être
plus précisément notre gilles qu'est ce
qu'elle pouvait bien faire en pleine
nuit aux roses est alors entré chez elle
enfin chez ses parents derrière la
maison de retraite elle est passé la
soirée chez des amis dans la cité à
cette heure là je suppose que tout le
monde dort mal personne n'a rien
remarqué cratie mon avis dans une petite
vieille cabine d'un point à l'impression
d'avoir entendu de voiture démarre et
aller vers une heure du matin rue de
l'enfer et c'est juste à côté
quel genre de voiture ça va pas dire
[Applaudissements]
bon tout le monde dont le terrain en
quelque chose à des buts de moindre
renseignement hébrard ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant-hier mardi seulement je vais scav
ensemble dans la copie noir du prince au
cours des tonnes au nom autour des corps
il saura le soir un très bon soir
d'automne
c'est ça qui est morte pour mesurer
mais quoi les la paix la paix ni de
ouidah squattant rendu début parce que
sa compagnie suisse à l'enterrement
léger star dans son élan la porte noire
du crep autour des cordes et sans rendre
le soir un très bon soir d'un talent est
là quand ils arrivent ils ont la côte
chinoise
ça va durer encore longtemps ce produit
mais comment voulez vous je me repose
aussi vous parler tout le temps mais si
vous êtes je travaille la nuit
enfin j'ai tellement vous et non la
petite news germes
tu sais le vieux gm a dû vous regardez
la vidéo qu'elle allait y avait la
petite 19 ans tout comme celle là voilà
bien je vais bien fort et vous monsieur
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pourquoi la du crime par dix
pas très content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patrick
ats
à
tiens
[Musique]
tiens tiens c'est pourquoi
oui
[Musique]
m
il
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans des stars grâce à guy haïr
voilà des années
holy compte dix gros on a chez lui un
prétendant aperçu un homme et la dorée
près du rosé autres lui voit la grèce à
l'étude
[Applaudissements]
ces frappes ou tard je peux encore
respect
masseret marins sans débat tout comme ça
non tu auras chalutier je regarde devant
comme mon grand-père moi je sens un
ingénieur à l'école
[Musique]
paul
m
e
et
[Musique]
l'art de rêve est en voyage depuis une
semaine encore un tuyau crevé rentrer à
la brigade
on sort aussi mauvaise bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél
m
[Musique]
e
que
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
est ce que tu fais là permis de toucher
à ça balkan salle d'austérité
à
[Applaudissements]
je croit patrick tu le dernier ya des
nouvelles du prime ce soir dont tiens je
vais allumer la télé c'est pas si on
arrêtait là certains n'ont pas encore je
ne vois pas moi qui le dit mais ça ça
l'assassin s'était plaint monsieur
noisette
allez dis pas de bêtises chine et le
moment elle est connectée qui passe à
celle du score de van cher sonne rexel
et où j habite au lit au lit
qui c'est celui-là c'est de leur gardien
de la marée motrice
mais qu'est ce qui fait alors aller doit
surveiller les vannes
où ça conforte allaitent
[Musique]
bien bougés par n'arrive jamais ça
cherchant à passer rivasi 312 de 47 312
de 47
comment me recevait vous parler ici 312
je vous reçois 5 sur 5 au fort dalet un
nouveaux cadavres
je répète aux forts dalet un nouveaux
cadavres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
patrick le xiii a été bouleversé par
l'installation d'un certain moselle chez
ses parents il a immédiatement ressenti
une hostilité profonde et instinctive
anvers locataires qu'ils considèrent
comme un intrus
peu après l'arrivée de moselle saint
malo la découverte du cadavre d'une
jeune fille mais la ville en émoi et
patrick cherche en savoir davantage sur
l'identité du mystérieux locataires en
rentrant de son travail au petit matin
mosès est il qu'un deuxième cadavre
vient d'être découvert
[Applaudissements]
rochefort gisèle marguerite de
paramètres 22 ans elle travaillait à la
poste centrale
elle rentrait chez elle regardez elle
aussi exactement comme les autres
compétiteurs mais cette fois chapuis bon
c'est pas grand chose mais on a trouvé
ça près du corps un bouton avec une
ancre de marine et la d'empreintes de
bottes oui on fait un moulage
[Applaudissements]
à votre avis
un des bottes et des cabans presque tout
le monde en porte ici pas forcément des
marins on va quand même faire des
recherches de ce côté là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui j'ai procureur le capital est en
route
on va certainement pas tarder oui oui
mais de voir ce qu'ils ont oui un coup
de téléphone chef quelqu'un prétend
avoir vu un marin s'est tenue près du
ford à être grand blond avec un doit
voter avec un doigt en paix c'est la
deuxième fois que je traîne ça je fais
un appel par radio vous ordre diffusé le
signalement dans tous les lieux publics
les cafés les beautés du port les
bureaux de tabac retard
[Applaudissements]
canam
sensationnelle découverte de la cité
d'aleth d'un deuxième cadavre est
découvert
rôtir autres oloron le marin comment
tous ex camarade gendarmes m'ont dit
pour des bottes et un caban les pâquis
main qui porte du botia qu'avant
qu'est ce tu fabriques maintenant sera
pas non je fait rentrer avant la nuit
fatale à savoir comment sera resté là
c'est complètement faux autant prix me
suis mouillé il service qui c'est qui va
s'en occuper et bon bon bon bon ça va
figer matin 6h30 ce matin son agent les
yeux sagnol s écoute monsieur tamek et
toutes les forêts paris dont albert
médecine à cognac
[Musique]
ah non monsieur s'était pas ici qu'il
faut vous adresser mes à la mairie bon
ben vous savez où se trouve la mairie
d'étrangers une quittance de loyer même
une facture d'électricité principe à des
coupes ici et justifier votre adresse
et surtout n'oubliez rien vous seriez
obligés d'y retourner la lessive
attention à la mairie fermée le samedi
ce qu'ils cherchent quelqu'un par le
chef vient de sortir il attendre ah oui
bien sûr et qu'est-ce que tu vivais
exactement si tu peux me dire ah c'est
la même chose
thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment s'appelle-t-il aulas swenson
nationalité il est belafkih landes et
demandez lui ce qu'il faisait entre 2h
et 3h du matin la nuit dernière en afin
de demander y aussi lui lui lui you ici
à bord de la navette août la noche jouer
à la star passe
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi il avait son caban ils étaient
sales prête pas le laisser parler non il
est à la soutenir
oui il avait des tâches des poubelles
mais les boutons ça peut toujours se
recoudre
regardez combien de choses
[Applaudissements]
en dehors du fait qu'il a des bottes et
un kabore qu'est ce qui te fait dire ça
toutou makisi lui est à jamais d'autres
locataires chez toi mon ami tu n'aimes
pas qu'il y ait quelqu'un d'autre que
tes parents ta maison zilli l'arrêter on
va d'abord vérifier il faut être sûr que
c'est lui le coupable
allez rentrer chez toi et penser à tout
ça qu'est ce que tu veux d'autres ni un
ami cris mais s'il tient on regarde ne
vais pas signer ce sera pour plus tard
allait bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben oui 95 et le voilier école de la
marine de guerre des marques tu connais
du don n'est pas tout mon grand père
était terminé pour tout de suite
sait on n'arrête pas les gens comme ça
parce qu'un petit garçon effet depuis
son échange croyez pas vous mais si mais
si ya les déclarés chez toi varan
inquiète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non
[Musique]
au départ n'était pas là des coups de
téléphone des gens qui connaissaient le
criminel leur coin sans un bon frère oui
le lot habituel des dénonciations les
vérifier on est en train
moi j'ai entendu un enfant je voulais
comme donner le nom du meurtrier lui
aussi avait si les gosses sans mais
maintenant elle va finir
qu'est ce qu'un gardien de nuit qu'il
meure je sais pas j'ai demandé qu'on
passe aux fichiers dans la réponse alors
la porte notre main à couper
ces patrouilles pour le premier crime
ses camarades affirme qu'il était malade
et qui n'a pas bougé de sa couchette et
la nuit dernière ils seraient tous jouer
aux cartes jusqu'à 6h du matin allez
donc savoir si c'est vrai il faut
vérifier chaque pays
oublié mon vieux j'ai pas beaucoup dormi
depuis deux jours oui c'est vrai bon bah
allez vous poser à l'eau n'ont toujours
rien nous ne savons pas mon mari est
allé voir j entends qui relie aix
cuisine alors rien quitté l'école à 4
heures comme d'habitude rien d'anormal
prérentrée fêtait là d'ailleurs je sais
pas il a dû ressortir
allez vous tuez les par tous j'ai vu
tout le monde personne ne l'a vu
[Musique]
c'est bon tu as magenta
bon alors je vais donc faire
non non vraiment il ne croit pas d'odeur
bon bah ramener le hockey
je m'y attendais
en ville ça ne marche pas d'être odeurs
qui lui coupe le flair et puis il a plu
cette nuit
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
nous allons diffuser son signalement à
toutes les brigades de la région
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah que
à quelques jours d'intervalle
on a découvert à saint malo les cadavres
de deux jeunes filles poignardé en
pleine nuit dans des lieux déserts la
gendarmerie interroge un marin
finlandais aux doigts coupés
comment s'appelle-t-il orlov le spencer
mais le petit patrick soupçonne un
certain moselle qui a pris pension chez
lui et qu'il considère comme un intrus
comme ses parents refuse de l'écouter il
vient faire part de ses soupçons
gendarmes sursis lui après quoi il
disparaît malgré un dispositif de
recherches mis en place dans la nuit
malgré le chien policier
l'enfant reste introuvable et d'ivoire
d'ici là se cherche un set lui les
intimes a cédé 2 ceni sera comme si on
est passé de travailler avec les degrés
ils s'appellent comme un gosse le 13 et
patrick le 13
13/10 maladie dans lé là dans son bureau
pour moi oui
battus dans le gosse qui a disparu oui
eh bien c'est celui qui est venu hier
venus view bas ici vous le savez bien je
vous en ai parlé hier soir quoi de glace
qui voulait dénoncer un gardien venu
c'est cela le chien du flairé l'odeur de
l'enfant dans la gendarmerie c'est pour
ça que vous pouvez pas me dire plutôt
new trabi n'est chef ce type qui
l'accusé vous avez la réponse du fichier
mais oui oui négatif aucune condamnation
balle et quand même le chercher en
vitesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais le sud s'il vous plaît pourquoi
quelques vérifications à faire
profession veilleur de nuit et où l
usine marémotrice
il ya longtemps que vous êtes à saint
malo une semaine à peu près et alors
avant j'habitais strasbourg strasbourg
adresse 285 du colonel brignoles
profession à strasbourg guardian lui
aussi non dessinateur industriel
dessinateur industriel
pourquoi avez vous quitté strasbourg
comme ça et pourquoi êtes-vous venu à
saint malo vous avez des parents des
amis
pourquoi saint malo pourquoi pas
alors
ne voulait rien dire vous avez quelque
chose à me reprocher tant pour le moment
rien
je trouve seulement curieux qui est
dessinateur industriel quitte
brusquement strasbourg comme ça sans
raison et bien s'installer à saint malo
il ne connaît personne et kitty face
embauché comme gardien de nuit on a
droit de faire ce qu'on veut exane
[Applaudissements]
seulement voilà depuis que vous êtes
assez mal autres qui se passe de drôles
de choses on a assassiné deux femmes ben
oui ça m'a moins je ne les connaissais
pas
et le petit patrick disparu depuis hier
vous ne connaissiez pas non plus mais
bien sûr que si quand même écouté je
peux faire une enquête à strasbourg je
finirai bien par savoir pourquoi vous
avez deux parties mais cela prendra du
temps
[Applaudissements]
alors vous feriez mieux de me dire tout
de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est ce ma femme et mon fils il
habite strasbourg pendant les cent morts
ya six mois comment ça il fallait aller
chercher le petit à l'école
c'est en rentrant à la maison un camion
c'est pour ça que vous détestiez le
petit patrick mais non je déteste pas
[Applaudissements]
on s'est un peu compliqué
oui pour vous mon adjudant à l'eau oui
je préférerais dans un instant mon
capitaine merci asseyez vous mangez
[Applaudissements]
ils sont morts sur le coup
sa femme oui son fils a duré plus d'une
semaine
le camionneur on l'a laissé en liberté
rupture d'essieu ce n'était pas de sa
faute mais lui il a failli devenir fou
on a été obligé de l'interné dans un
hôpital psychiatrique pendant six mois
qu'en est il sorti il ya une semaine
juste avant de venir ici
kerry ça allait dans savoir qu'elle ait
deux filles parce que ça aussi vous avez
le mettre sur le dos je ne voulais rien
sur le dos ça fait très bien plus
connais cette page jamais rien ne prouve
que nos trier les connaissait elles ont
été tuées toutes les deux dans les
endroits déserts en pleine nuit
mais justement je travaille vous
travaillez c'est beaucoup dire une ronde
de temps en temps ça vous laisse du
temps libre et de l' usine marémotrice
aux roses est en bicyclette il faut pas
dix minutes tu foutez moi la paix mais
pourquoi j'aurais pu ces deux femmes
quand vous m'arrêtez on va vous
installer dans une pièce à côté
le temps de vérifier vos déclarations
allez on sait si
[Applaudissements]
gens sérieux
plus en tout cas malgré dispositif de
recherches
[Applaudissements]
une fois de plus nous lançons un appel à
tous ceux qui auraient pu voir le petit
patrick le xiii dont on est sans
nouvelles depuis hier soir
regardez bien cette photo si vous pouvez
fournir le moindre renseignement à son
sujet mettez vous immédiatement en
rapport avec la station régionale de
rennes téléphone alors oui j'écoute avec
la brigade de gendarmerie à ces points
la montre dont ils n'ont toujours rien
[Musique]
voyez estomacs fragiles
non nombreux lots non mais comme yvonne
affirmé m
[Applaudissements]
oh ouais haut
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ach passe bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe iii donné l'alerté mais
tellement des barrages paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
bakou
à quelques jours d'intervalle deux
jeunes filles ont été poignardé en
pleine nuit à saint malo le petit
patrick soupçonne un certain mouzet qui
a pris pension chez lui et qu'il
considère comme un acte les gens comme
ça comme ses parents refuse de l'écouter
il se rend à la gendarmerie pour faire
part de ses soupçons puis il disparaît
et demeura trouva mosey est alors
longuement interrogé par les gendarmes
entrent dans la maison
un camion c'est pour ça que vous
détestez le petit patrick ne déteste pas
mais l'identité du meurtrier est
brusquement découverte au moment où ils
s'attaquent une troisième jeune fille
aidé par deux copains il réussit à
prendre la fuite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
couche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dangereux dangereux bien sûr qu'il est
dangereux et va tuer deux parties tu dis
pas non
[Musique]
là
aliot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont pas par la terreur
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à saint malo on est toujours sans
nouvelles du petit patrick le 13
disparus depuis hier soir la gendarmerie
nous communique qu'au moment de sa
disparition l'enfant portait un pantalon
noir un pull-over rouge et un blouson
jaune toute personne pouvant fournir des
renseignements
comme manger quelque chose mon chéri
l'année papier c'est un malade et
psychiatres diront sûrement qu'il est
irresponsable
mais ses copains le savaient et n'ont
rien dit c'est eux qu'on devrait
condamner pour l'enfant vous croyez que
c'est lui non
[Applaudissements]
et moi s'est il est toujours ici oui
mais vous l'interrogez pas il ne dira
rien de plus ou bien ils hument ans il
continuera ou alors il n'en sais rien
moi je pencherais plutôt pour la seconde
hypothèse
je suis pas bien sûr mais une impression
non c'est pas gentil bana oubliez pas qu
ils sortent d'un psychiatrique
je sais bien non le petit patrick qui
fait trop penser à son propre fils pour
qu'il eut fait du mal
son gosse avait le même âge y est
content que j'interrogeais il m'a dit
qu'il lui ressemblait peut-il être alors
ce môme si je le savais
les journalistes sont toujours là alors
leur faire une déclaration pour les
finlandais
si seulement j'arrive à comprendre
[Applaudissements]
chapuis m'avait appelé mon adjudant wii
permet la vente
dites moi comment ça s'est passé l'autre
jour avec le petit patrick quand il est
venu ici
bref je voulais déjà dit oui justement
je repense à tout ça et je me demande si
la disparition du petit patrick n'est
pas de votre faute de ma faute
vous êtes jeune japonais beaucoup de
choses à apprendre et les enfants c'est
pas facile à connaître l'arrivée de
mauzé a bouleversé le petit patrick son
père lui a dit là dessus on découvre
deux gros coups sur vous la ville est en
ébullition on ne parle que de ça alors
il vient une idée
l'homme qui s'est introduit chez ses
parents qui a semé le désordre son
existence cet homme-là il meurtrier
alors qu'est ce qu'il fait il en parle à
ses copains qui se moque de lui il en
parle à ses parents quittent gronde
alors il tient ici chez nous les
gendarmes
c'est l'ordre l'autorité là où intensité
on l'écoutera armées je l'écoutais au
vous devez envoyer promener maman du
tout aussi quand il vous demande si vous
avez vu faire signer sa déposition voulu
dit non quand il vous demande si vous
allez arrêter mauzé pour lui dit encore
non personne ne le prend au sérieux
personne ne le croit c'est une véritable
conspiration de tous les adultes y
compris de moselle moselle qui est
toujours en liberté et dont il a peur
alors qu'est ce que vous auriez fait à
sa place
moi sa place j'aurais tout planté là et
je serais parti c'est probablement ce
qu'il a fait mais ou tranchant
je sais vous plaît
le bureau du port de saint malo appel
marie-annick le bureau du port de saint
malo appel marie-annick m'entendais vous
ici de mariannick gersois quatre sur
cinq bureaux du port de saint malo
parler je vous écoute
mariannick la gendarmerie de saint malo
va vous communiquer un message on
recherche patrick le 13 11 ans embarqué
clandestinement à saint malon dans la
soirée du 15 ou dans la nuit du 15 au 16
je répète patrick lopez estimant à saint
malo dans la soirée du 15 dans la nuit
du 15 au 16
ici le marianne et nous avons fouillé
tout le bâtiment il n'est pas à boire
pas trop vite passager clandestin
négatif après visite total du bateau
n'est pas bon aucun grassi dans la
galerie sur le pont avant vérifier pas
d'enfants à bord
le bureau du port de saint malo
ici la ville de dinant mersa vélo ici le
bureau du port de saint malo ville de
dinant je vous reçois cinq sur cinq par
les fouiller tout le bâtiment partout
dans laquelle partout eh ben on l'a
retrouvé votre gamin il était bien
implanté
filez vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
comment ils étaient cent p te lui foutra
une de ses tournées dont il se
souviendrait vous rendez compte du temps
qui me fait perdre à cause de ce morveux
excusez-nous commandant merci allez
viens patrick
notamment je vous conduis mais non ils
ne demanderont pas eh ben ils auront
tort moi si j'étais à leur place tien
ou si vous aime les mairies qui n'en n'a
pas arrêté c'était pas lui l'assassin
doucet j'espérais tout cela
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
vous
elle
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
accueil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]